the Los Angeles County District Attorney
created a special task force to
investigate allegations of sexual abuse
in Hollywood the team will look into
accusations against film producer Harvey
Weinstein director James Toback actor ed
Westwick and others Jamie yuccas is in
Los Angeles with how criminal probes are
intensifying in these cases Jamie good
morning good morning the Los Angeles
County District Attorney Jackie Lacey
says her task force will work in
coordination with the LAPD and Beverly
Hills Police Department now the task
force will be specially trained deputy
district attorneys and veteran sex
crimes prosecutors they're gonna work
together she says to ensure a uniform
approach to the legal review nearly 70
women have now come forward with
allegations against Harvey Weinstein who
as you guys know is also being
investigated by New York City
prosecutors the LA Times says more than
200 women have accused director James
Toback of sexual misconduct and actor
Edie Westwick is the subject of two rape
allegations from 2014 all three men have
denied wrongdoing now sex crime cases
can be difficult to prove I can tell you
that the DA miss lacy says that no
criminal filings have been presented to
her by law enforcement at this point so
she is not moving forward with any cases
by the way she does run the largest sex
crimes unit in the country Liana Jamie
thank you